This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。真人保证。2%。这就是有电梯时还选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会迎来一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的自己。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。收听《回顾往事》播客。从1979年开始，对我和说那是重要时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每集我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何度过那段时期的。与我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那是疯狂的一年。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts,
在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾往事》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《艰难成长的法则》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖姆斯。这个节目探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都无法真正安全进行的坦诚对话，但你是在与一位懂行的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人背负着盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着。并不意味着你需要这样做。在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts上收听《艰难成长的法则》，
or wherever you get your podcast. Hello and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. It has been a while. I took some time off to do my final exams and I have officially finished my degree, which is super exciting, a little bit nerve-wracking as well. I think next week I really want to do an episode on like the psychology of life transitions because I think it would be quite interesting to kind of discuss especially as I prepare to move cities, say goodbye to Canberra, start my new job, all of those things.
或者在你获取播客的任何地方。你好，欢迎回到《二十几岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们探讨二十几岁时的一些重大变化和转变，以及它们对我们心理的意义。好久不见了。我花了一些时间准备期末考试，现在我正式完成了学位，这超级令人兴奋，当然也让人有点紧张。我想下周我真的想做一期关于生活转变心理学的节目，因为我觉得讨论这个会挺有趣的，特别是我正准备搬去别的城市，跟堪培拉告别，开始我的新工作，所有这些事情。
Yeah, it feels like adulthood is really beginning and it's a period. It's pretty full of like nostalgia for like my first year self, excitement, nerves. But that's next week. For this week's episode, I'm pulling something from the archives. We're going to talk about the psychology of attraction. So I did a lot of research into this a few weeks ago, but never got around to recording it because I was obviously stressed. But today's the day.
是的，感觉成年生活真的开始了，这段时期充满了我对大一自己的怀念，还有兴奋和紧张。但那是下周的事。至于本周的节目，我将从资料库里翻出一些内容。我们要聊聊吸引力的心理学。其实几周前我对此做了很多研究，但一直没空录音，因为我当时压力太大了。不过今天就是录制的时候。
I've just been really fascinated by what creates attraction as a single person and why we like certain people and don't like others, especially in our 20s when it seems, you know, everyone is having these flings and these attraction and these crushes. to people and we go out to clubs and, you know, we meet people and we have this spark. So what kind of creates this so-called spark from a psychological perspective? We're going to explore the answer to that. But I wanted to take more of a social psychology approach rather than biological as we traditionally hear about, you know, obviously we can't really talk about attraction without talking about the neural and hormonal origins. But I want to discuss more so how attraction forms in a
作为单身人士，我一直对是什么产生了吸引力、为什么我们喜欢某些人而讨厌其他人感到非常着迷，尤其是在我们二十几岁的时候，似乎每个人都在经历这些短暂的恋情、吸引和暗恋，对别人产生好感，我们去夜店，然后，你知道的，我们遇见了什么人，擦出了火花。那么，从心理学的角度来看，究竟是什么创造了这种所谓的“火花”呢？我们将探讨这个答案。不过，比起我们传统上听说的生物学角度，我想采取更多的社会心理学方法，当然，我们在探讨吸引力时，确实离不开神经和荷尔蒙的起源。但我更想探讨吸引力是如何在
social environment for romantic partners, obviously, but also friendships as well. Why are we attracted to certain people and not others? Okay, so there is this theory, often flaunted by the skeptics of love, that attraction is merely chemical, love is merely chemical, romance, all of those things. It's quite like a biological reductionist approach that we can explain everything based on what neurotransmitters are released, what hormones are released and those kind of things. And attraction occurs because of hormones, mostly related to procreation and sex that are released when we see someone who arouses us or meets our preferences or our love map, which is something I'm going to discuss a bit later. And it's attraction, like that instantaneous attraction, it's often associated with high levels of serotonin and estrogen for women and testosterone for men. And we find people initially attractive because of what is unlocked in our brains and bodies.
社会环境中形成的，当然包括浪漫伴侣，也包括友谊。为什么我们会被某些人吸引，而不是其他人？好了，有一个经常被爱情怀疑论者标榜的理论，即吸引力纯粹是化学反应，爱情纯粹是化学反应，浪漫，所有这些都是如此。这很像一种生物还原论的方法，我们可以根据释放了哪些神经递质、释放了哪些荷尔蒙以及诸如此类的事情来解释一切。吸引力的产生是因为荷尔蒙，主要与生育和性有关，当我们看到一个让我们兴奋、符合我们的偏好或爱图谱的人时，这些荷尔蒙就会释放，爱图谱是我稍后要讨论的内容。吸引力，比如那种瞬间的吸引力，通常与女性体内高水平的血清素和雌激素以及男性体内的睾酮有关。我们最初觉得某人有吸引力，是因为我们的大脑和身体中被解开了某些密码。
Also, when I was researching this for the women who are listening or for those who identify as female or who have periods, it's really interesting because you're more likely to find people attractive during certain periods of like your menstrual cycle. So right after you like finish your period before you like begin to ovulate before you're like most fertile, I guess, that's the period where you're most likely to experience like attraction, which is really interesting and that drops off after you've ovulated towards like when your period's about to start. So attraction can be caused by things like physical appearance, obviously, but also other factors like smell. So a study that was done this year actually, well, was published this year, found that women with certain scents are more attractive to men.
另外，当我为听节目的女性，或者为那些认为自己是女性或有月经的人研究这个时，真的很有趣，因为你在月经周期的某些阶段更容易觉得别人有吸引力。也就是在你经期结束之后、排卵开始之前，也就是你最肥沃的时候，我想，那是你最容易体验到吸引力的时期，这真的很有趣，而在你排卵之后，一直到你快要来月经的时候，这种吸引力就会下降。因此，吸引力可能是由外表等因素引起的，显而易见，还有气味等其他因素。事实上，今年的一项研究——准确说是今年发表的一项研究发现，具有特定气味的女性对男性更有吸引力。
So it turns out that we are most appealing when we have high estrogen and low progressive. levels, which is, like I said, around when we're ovulating. And this balance of hormones indicates high female fertility, which is a huge kind of driver of attraction. I feel like when we're thinking about it from a sex perspective or a mating perspective. And the research has explained that it makes sense that, you know, men find women more attractive while they're at this stage because of that instinct to mate and create offspring. Another one, another factor, that also has a big kind of role to play in attraction is a voice. So another study a few years ago, so a bit outdated,
事实证明，当我们拥有高雌激素和低孕酮水平时，我们最具吸引力，正如我所说，这大约在我们排卵的时候。这种荷尔蒙的平衡表明女性生育能力很高，这是吸引力的一个巨大驱动力。我觉得当我们从性的角度或交配的角度来考虑这个问题时。研究解释说，男人在这个阶段觉得女人更有吸引力是有道理的，因为有交配和繁衍后代的本能。另一个因素，对吸引力也起着很大作用的因素，是声音。所以几年前的另一项研究，虽然有点过时，
but it found that women prefer men with low voices. And there could be something inherently biological in this, as deeper voices have been linked to producing healthier children in the wild, lower pitch is associated with being bigger. It might also indicate greater testosterone levels if your voice is low, which is really interesting. So smell, voice, all of these things that we initially get from someone when we first meet them. And other factors that kind of create that rush of serotonin that accompanies attraction may be certain features like muscles and how tall you are, if you have good
但它发现女性更喜欢低沉声音的男性。这可能具有内在的生物学原因，因为在野外，更深沉的声音与产下更健康的后代有关，较低的音调与体型更大有关。如果你的声音低沉，这也可能表明睾酮水平更高，这真的很有趣。所以气味、声音，所有这些我们在初次见面时从某人身上最初获得的特征。其他一些会产生伴随吸引力而来的血清素激增的因素可能是某些特征，如肌肉、身高、皮肤是否健康、
skin, facial traits, tan skin, posture, all of which can be indicative of someone's fertility, obviously, but also the capacity to protect, to care and to nurture. So although instant attraction might be biologically based, it's also influenced by a number of social and environmental factors that more so allow love and other feelings of attraction, but more than that to kind of blossom. Okay, but now moving on to what leads to attraction and friendship beyond that initial spark, that initial first glance, love at first sight thing. So there are four factors that psychologists often identify as leading to attraction. So that's proximity, physical attractiveness, which we've kind of already discussed, similarity and liking those who like us. So proximity is probably the strongest predictor of attraction.
面部特征、晒黑的皮肤、体态，所有这些都可以表明一个人的生育能力，显然还有保护、照顾和培育的能力。因此，虽然瞬间的吸引力可能是基于生物学的，但它也受到许多社会和环境因素的影响，这些因素更能让爱情和其他吸引力的感觉，甚至不仅仅是这些，得以绽放。好了，现在我们来谈谈除了最初的火花、最初的第一眼和一见钟情之外，是什么引领了吸引力和友谊。心理学家通常认为有四个因素会导致吸引力。这就是邻近性、我们已经讨论过的身体吸引力、相似性以及喜欢那些喜欢我们的人。因此，邻近性可能是吸引力的最强预测指标。
The more we kind of see and interact with a person, the more likely we are to become friends with them or to become attracted to them. This is really interesting. There was a study that, you know, this was a theory at first, and there was a study done to kind of confirm this hypothesis. And it was done at the Westgate House community at MIT. So it's like a college, basically. And they tracked attraction, relationships, and friendship formation amongst people
我们越是经常看到并与一个人互动，我们就越有可能与他们成为朋友，或者被他们吸引。这真的很有趣。曾有一项研究，（起初这只是一个理论），进行了一项研究来证实这个假设。它是在麻省理工学院的韦斯特盖特住宅社区进行的。所以这基本上就像一个大学。他们追踪了人们之间的吸引力、关系和友谊的形成。
at various apartment buildings and apartment rooms. And residents had been assigned their apartments at random, which is great. We know random allocation makes an experiment a lot more generalized. generalizable? Yes, more valid, more reliable. But researchers asked the participants to name the people that they were most attracted to and their three closest friends within the living quarters. 65% of them named people who lived on the same floor. So all people who even lived in the same apartment because it was shared. Forty-one percent of them said next door neighbors, so those right across from them.
在各个公寓楼和公寓房间里。居民的公寓是随机分配的，这太棒了。我们知道随机分配使实验更具普适性？是的，更有效、更可靠。但研究人员要求参与者说出他们居住区内最吸引他们的人以及他们三个最亲密的朋友。其中65%的人说的是住在同一层楼的人。甚至所有住在同一间公寓里的人，因为那是共用的。41%的人说是隔壁邻居，也就是正对门的人。
22% said two doors down. So you can kind of see as they get farther away, the rate of attraction or friendship kind of drops off. And then 10% of them said the opposite end of the hallway. So it kind of seems that attraction and the level of friendship that we have towards people or how attracted we are to them as a person is related to just the physical distance between people. But it's not just like the physical distance.
22%的人说隔两道门。所以你可以看出，随着距离越来越远，吸引力或友谊的比例有所下降。然后10%的人说是走廊的另一端。因此，似乎吸引力和我们对人们的友好程度，或者我们作为一个人被他们吸引的程度，与人与人之间的物理距离有关。但这不仅仅仅是物理距离。
it's also functional distance. So if there are features in your life or where you're living that make it more likely that you'll become close to someone or interact with them, that also creates attraction. So if, for example, people are living on the same pathway or someone who's living at the bottom of the stairs where you have to pass by every day, they also have a greater chance of meeting people and building those friendships, but also that attraction with people that they meet. So the proximity effect, it does seem largely to be due to mere exposure. So the mere exposure effect, it's basically the tendency to rate stimuli more positively after
这也是功能距离。因此，如果你生活中的某些特征或你居住的地方增加了你与某人亲近或互动的可能性，这也创造了吸引力。因此，例如，如果人们住在同一条小路上，或者住在每天必须路过的楼梯底部的人，他们也有更多机会结识人并建立这些友谊，同时也对他们遇到的人产生吸引力。因此，邻近效应在很大程度上似乎是由单纯曝光引起的。因此，单纯曝光效应基本上是一种倾向，即在
you've been exposed to them repeatedly. So in the case of attraction, you rate someone as more attractive or you're more interested in them the more that you're exposed to them. So we see, the more we see people, the more familiar we become with them, the more likely we are to be attracted to them, to become friends with them, to pursue something with them. And obviously, like, there are limitations. Like, if the person's really mean, doesn't really matter how close they are. It's probably worse if they're closer to you and you don't like them.
你反复接触刺激后，对刺激的评价会更积极。在吸引力的情况下，你接触某人的频率越高，你对他们的评价就越高，或者你对他们就越感兴趣。因此，我们看到人们的次数越多，我们对他们就越熟悉，我们就越有可能被他们吸引，与他们成为朋友，与他们发展关系。显然，比如，这里面也是有限制的。例如，如果这个人真的很卑鄙，他们靠得多近其实并不重要。如果他们离你很近而你又不喜欢他们，那可能更糟糕。
But in general, proximity effect does seem to kind of hold up. And it's also to do with familiarity. It builds affection and liking. So the more exposure, the higher frequency of exposure, the more favorable you are. So that is one of those core things that relates to who you find attractive. It's how close you are distance-wise. The second one that we talked about that I noticed was similarity. And this really fuels growing relationships and attraction to someone.
但总的来说，邻近效应似乎确实成立。这还与熟悉度有关。它能建立喜爱和好感。因此，曝光越多，曝光频率越高，你就越讨人喜欢。所以这是与你发现谁有吸引力有关的核心因素之一。这就是你们在距离上的接近程度。我们谈到的第二点我注意到的是相似性。这真正推动了不断发展的关系和对某人的吸引力。
So it's not just the physical distance, but it's match between our interests, our attitudes, values, backgrounds, or personality, and those of another person. So if you share things in common, you're more likely to find someone attractive in the more likely a relationship is to evolve. Research evidence really strongly supports that similarity draws people together. I feel like it's a bit of a no-brainer. So, you know, think about your friends or the person you're in a relationship with or someone that you like. You're more likely to share common attitudes, you have things that you like in common. For example, if you like bike riding, obviously you're going to be more attracted to someone who shares that interest. Yeah, so if you share things in common, it kind of makes sense that attraction will evolve,
因此，这不仅仅是物理距离，而是我们的兴趣、态度、价值观、背景或个性与另一个人的匹配。如果你有共同点，你就更有可能发现某人有吸引力，关系也更有可能发展。研究证据强烈支持相似性将人们拉近。我觉得这是一个不用动脑筋的问题。所以，想想你的朋友、你的恋爱对象或者你喜欢的人。你们更有可能分享共同的态度，你们有共同喜欢的东西。例如，如果你喜欢骑自行车，显然你会更容易被也有这种兴趣的人吸引。是的，如果你有共同点，吸引力就会发展，这在某种程度上是有道理的，
especially because I guess people who are similar to us will like the same things as us, but also they validate our own characteristics and beliefs. So they provide us with this feeling that we are right, that what we like is right, that how we feel is right. And that's really important for our self-esteem, which is why we might be attracted to them because they validate us. and we also tend to make negative and automatic inferences about someone who disagrees with us on an important issue or who just likes the things that we like because that kind of provides a bit of hostility or kind of I don't know push back towards what we think is good in the world and liking is so powerful you know liking someone though if you just like who they are that it can make up for an absence of similarity So having things in common is important. But if you just really like someone, sometimes that doesn't even matter.
特别是由于我猜与我们相似的人会喜欢和我们一样的东西，而且他们也证实了我们自己的特征和信仰。因此，他们带给我们这样一种感觉：我们是正确的，我们喜欢的是正确的，我们的感觉是正确的。这对于我们的自尊非常重要，这就是为什么我们可能会被他们吸引，因为他们验证了我们。而且我们往往对那些在重要问题上与我们意见不分歧、或者只是喜欢我们喜欢的东西的人做出消极和自动的推断，因为这会带来一点敌意，或者对我们认为世界上美好的事物产生某种程度的抗拒，而且好感是如此强大，你知道的，如果你只是喜欢某人的为人，这种好感可以弥补相似性的缺失。因此，有共同点很重要。但如果你真的很喜欢一个人，有时这甚至都不重要。
And this is where the principle of reciprocity comes in. So we like people who like us, which kind of links back to that self-esteem, self-awareness hypothesis. Reciprocal liking sometimes occurs because of a self-fulfilling prophecy. So when we expect people to like us, we think that they like us, that elicits more favourable behaviour from us, which means they're more likely to be favourable or kind to us back. So there was a study done, I think in the 80s,
这就是互惠原则发挥作用的地方。所以我们喜欢喜欢我们的人，这有点回到了自尊、自我意识的假设。互惠好感有时是由自证预言引起的。因此，当我们期望别人喜欢我们、认为别人喜欢我们时，这会引发我们表现出更有利的态度，这意味着他们更有可能对我们表现出好感或友善。因此，曾做过一项研究，我想是在80年代，
right when like attraction psychology was starting to take place. And basically these two guys, Curtis and Miller, they got these college students to participate in pairs. And the pairs, both members of the pairs, they hadn't met each other before. And one member of each pair was selected randomly to know certain information that the other student either liked or disliked them. Obviously, this wasn't based on anything. The researchers made it up.
正值吸引力心理学开始兴起的时候。基本上，这两个人，柯蒂斯和米勒，他们让这些大学生以对子的形式参加。在这些对子中，双方彼此之前都不认识。每对中的其中一人被随机挑选，获悉某些信息，即另一个学生是喜欢他们还是不喜欢他们。显然，这不是基于任何事实。研究人员是捏造的。
So they kind of like manipulated the experiment. So one member of the pair was told, oh yeah, this person that you're meeting today, they really like you or they've heard about you. And, you know, maybe in another pair, the research would be like, oh, they actually dislike you. I don't think that you guys will get along. So those who believed that they were liked initially, they behaved more positively. They disclosed more, disagreed less, and behaved just in general more warmly to their partner. Whereas those who believed they weren't liked actually ended up getting along with the person a lot less, even if initial personality tests or interest tests had proven that they actually had quite a lot in common.
所以他们有点像操纵了实验。因此，其中一人被告知：“哦，是的，你今天见到的这个人，他们真的很喜欢你，或者他们听说过你。”你知道，在另一对中，研究人员可能会说：“哦，他们其实不喜欢你。我不认为你们会合得来。”因此，那些最初相信自己被喜欢的人表现得更积极。他们透露得更多，反对得更少，总体上对他们的伴侣表现得更热情。然而，那些认为自己不受欢迎的人，最终与这个人的相处要少得多，即使最初的个性测试或兴趣测试证明他们实际上有很多共同点。
So the partner kind of mirrored that of the other member of the pair. So if you thought someone wasn't going to like you, probably weren't going to be as warm to them because you were initially hostile or, you know, vigilant against an attack against your sense of self. This is obviously, maybe not obviously, but interestingly, moderated by self-esteem. So people with a negative self-concept, so they don't really like themselves,
所以伴侣某种程度上反映了对子中另一个成员的行为。因此，如果你认为某人不会喜欢你，你可能就不会对他们那么热情，因为你最初是充满敌意的，或者对攻击你自我感的东西保持警惕。显然，这受到自尊的调节，也许这并不明显，但有趣的是。因此，具有负面自我概念的人，也就是他们真的不喜欢自己，
they don't see themselves very favorably, they respond quite differently in this experiment, which the researchers noticed and would prefer to meet someone who has criticized them before who the researchers said didn't like them. If someone is, it's friendly to them and you have a negative self-concept, then that behaviour kind of appears unwarranted because you believe that you're not a good person and they may not respond positively. So that reciprocation is a huge part of attraction, liking someone who likes us. It makes a lot of sense. Obviously, the big one, the one that most people probably think about in terms of attraction, in terms of attraction, it's just physical attractiveness. You know, you just find certain people hot.
他们对自己的看法并不是很积极，他们在实验中的反应完全不同，研究人员注意到了这一点，并且他们宁愿见一个曾经批评过他们、或者研究人员说不喜欢他们的人。如果有人对你很友好，而你又有负面的自我概念，那么这种行为就会显得毫无根据，因为你相信自己不是个好人，他们可能不会做出积极的反应。因此，这种互惠是吸引力的巨大组成部分，喜欢一个喜欢我们的人。这很有道理。显然，最重要的一点，大多数人在考虑吸引力时可能会想到的一点，就是外表吸引力。你知道，你只是觉得某些人很性感。
You like what they look like, I guess. And, you know, the research checks up against that. Men and women both prefer attractive partners and are more likely to say that they're more attractive. Or they have greater attraction towards them physically and greater arousal. person is traditionally attractive. This is one of the best indicators of whether someone would like to date someone. So people, they often attribute positive qualities to those who are more attractive. My friend Meg and I were talking about this other day, how attractive people have it so much easier because I think people presume that physically attractive people possess other socially
我想，你只是喜欢他们的外表。而且，研究也印证了这一点。男性和女性都更喜欢有吸引力的伴侣，并且更有可能说他们更有吸引力。或者他们对这些人的生理吸引力和唤醒感更高。这个人传统上很有吸引力。这是衡量某人是否有意与他人约会的最有效指标之一。因此，人们经常将积极的品质归于那些更有吸引力的人。我和朋友梅格前几天还在聊这个，有吸引力的人生活要容易得多，因为我认为人们会假定外表有吸引力的人也拥有其他社会
desirable traits as well because it's indicative of so much more. And our culture kind of promotes this stereotype in less than subtle ways. You know, bad characters and movies, they're often ugly, whilst the good ones are beautiful like Cinderella and Snow White, they have perfect skin, beautiful bodies. And so we see them as good, whereas those that are ugly, we see them as unhealthy, we see them as cruel, we see them as bad. And this has like a lot of research behind it. People really want to hate on attractive people. Well, not really hate on attractive people, but they want to know why they kind of get further ahead in life, I guess.
可取的特征，因为这预示着更多的东西。我们的文化以毫不含糊的方式宣扬这种刻板印象。你知道，电影里的坏角色通常都很丑，而好角色则像灰姑娘和白雪公主那样美丽，他们拥有完美的皮肤、美好的身材。所以我们认为他们是好的，而那些丑陋的人，我们认为他们是不健康的，我们认为他们是残酷的，我们认为他们是坏的。这背后有很多研究支持。人们真的很想对有吸引力的人怀有敌意。好吧，也不是真的对有吸引力的人怀有敌意，但他们想知道为什么这些人似乎在生活中走得更远。
So here's a few examples of how this attraction or attractiveness creates attraction or liking someone. So teachers, they often judge attractive students as more intelligent and unattractive students. Adults and nurses who are in pediatric wards, they often punish unattractive children more harshly. This study in Texas showed that a judge is more likely, or judges just correlationally, set lower bales and smaller fines for attractive suspects.
这里有一些例子说明这种吸引力或外貌如何产生吸引力或赢得好感。例如，老师们经常判定有吸引力的学生比没有吸引力的学生更聪明。在儿科病房的成年人和护士往往对没有吸引力的儿童惩罚更严厉。德克萨斯州的这项研究表明，法官更有可能（或者法官仅从相关性上讲）为有吸引力的嫌疑人设定较低的保释金和较小的罚款。
Attractive people make more money, they get better job ratings from their bosses. And this one is really interesting in terms of attachment and childhood development. Parents, they spend more time looking at attractive babies. And attractiveness of babies, if the baby was really cute, was linked to health and treatment in ICU. So nurses and doctors, not to say they're biased, this is obviously very implicit, but they tend to spend more time nurturing and caring for babies that look attractive, that look cute. So even in early life, it's really good to be good looking.
有吸引力的人赚更多钱，从老板那里获得更好的工作评价。在依恋和儿童发展方面，这一点非常有趣。父母花更多时间看着有吸引力的婴儿。婴儿的吸引力，如果婴儿真的很可爱，与健康和ICU的治疗有关。因此，护士和医生，并不是说他们有偏见，这显然是非常隐含的，但他们往往会花更多时间去培育和照顾看起来有吸引力、看起来可爱的婴儿。所以即使在生命的早期，长得好看也是非常好的。
You know, there's just other things as well, like attractive people, they're more seen as relaxed and outgoing. And that's a huge thing for attraction. If you think that someone has all of these desirable traits, just from looking at, you at them, obviously, that attraction is going to blossom pretty quickly. And it does create kind of a self-fulfilling prophecy. So because attractive people are more valued and favored, even from birth, this causes them to develop greater self-confidence. And if they're more liked, they might want that feeling to continue. So what ends up happening is they get more opportunities.
你知道，还有其他一些事情，比如有吸引力的人，他们更被视为放松和外向的。这对吸引力来说是一件大事。如果你仅仅通过看一眼就认为某人拥有所有这些理想的特征，显然，这种吸引力会相当快地绽放。而且它确实会产生一种自证预言。因此，由于有吸引力的人更受重视和青睐，甚至从出生起就是这样，这导致他们培养出更大的自信。如果他们更受欢迎，他们可能会希望这种感觉继续下去。所以最终发生的是他们得到了更多的机会。
they're more valued so that those other kind of attributes and skills and behaviours that make someone attractive or likable develop from that. And just in terms of like general attractiveness, it's really interesting to note that there is like a lot of cross-cultural consistency in terms of body features and what kind of people we're going to find attractive just from the surface level. So across different cultures, women, In terms of their facial structure, we like people with large and widely separated eyes, small nose, small chin, but also wide cheekbones and narrow cheeks.
他们受到更多重视，因此使某人具有吸引力或讨人喜欢的其他属性、技能和行为也由此发展起来。仅仅就一般吸引力而言，有趣的是，在身体特征以及我们在表层面上会觉得什么样的人有吸引力方面，存在着大量的跨文化一致性。因此，在不同文化中，女性的面部结构，我们喜欢大而分得很开的眼睛、小鼻子、小下巴，但也有宽颧骨和窄脸颊。
So if you think about the traditional model, like the Kendall Jenner's of the world, they have all those features. Men on the other hand, very different. We want a square jaw, we want small eyes, thin lips, bushy eyebrows, those kind of things. And a lot of people from different cultures agree on what it's attractive in a face. There's been so many studies that have shown that people across the world find the same types of faces very attractive. And even infants show this. They prefer the same photographs of adults and they're often the attractive adults,
所以如果你想想传统的模特，比如世界上的肯达尔·詹娜，她们就拥有所有这些特征。另一方面，男性则非常不同。我们想要方下巴、小眼睛、薄嘴唇、浓密的眉毛诸如此类。来自不同文化背景的许多人都认同一张脸的吸引力所在。有无数的研究表明，世界各地的人们都觉得同类型的脸非常有吸引力。甚至婴儿也表现出这一点。他们更喜欢同一张成年人的照片，而这些通常都是有吸引力的成年人，
which I think is really interesting in terms of whether attraction to certain features is made even biological and linked to that health and well-being kind of perspective. So attraction towards physical features may be where the idea of love at first sight has come from. We see it in movies and in books. It's a classical archetype of love of seeing someone and falling in love with them, knowing the other one. But is this really real? Is this a real thing? I think a more important mechanism by which humans become captivated by someone,
我认为这在某种程度上非常有趣，即对某些特征的吸引力是否甚至是天生的，并与健康和幸福的视角联系在一起。因此，对身体特征的吸引力可能就是一见钟情这个概念的来源。我们在电影和书中都能看到它。这是爱的经典原型，看到某人并爱上他们，了解另一个人。但这是真的吗？这是一件真实的事情吗？我认为人类被某人迷住的一个更重要的机制，
It's due to your love map. This was a concept created by a sexologist called John Money, very good name. So long before you fixate on a specific person that you find attractive for various reasons, you've developed a map. It's kind of like a template within your brain that determines what arouses you sexually, what drives you to fall in love with one person rather than another, what drives you to be friends with one person rather than another, to find someone attractive, basically.
这是由于你的爱图谱。这是由一位名叫约翰·莫尼的性学家创造的概念，名字很好记。早在你迷恋因各种原因而具有吸引力的特定之人很久之前，你就已经绘制了一张地图。它有点像你大脑中的一个模板，决定了是什么在性方面唤醒了你，是什么驱使你爱上某个人而不是另一个人，是什么驱使你与某个人交朋友而不是另一个人，基本上就是觉得某人有吸引力。
And these love maps, they vary from one individual to the next. So some people get turned on, you know, by a business suit or a doctor's uniform, large, large boobs, small feet, laughter. It's all kind of varied, but that averageness and that kind of notion of symmetry still wins out. So in this one study, these psychologists selected 32 faces of Caucasian women only. and using computers they averaged all of their features and then they showed these images to college peers and of the 32 photographs of real female faces only three of them were rated as more appealing than these mixed photos of all the averaged features so that's really interesting this kind of idea of averageness and symmetry is really important and they don't really know why um obviously The world does not share the same sexual ideals of Caucasian students from some university in America.
这些爱图谱因人而异。所以有些人会被商务西装或医生制服、大胸、小脚、笑声所激起性欲。这一切都大同小异，但那种平均感和对称性的概念仍然占据上风。因此在这项研究中，这些心理学家仅选择了32张白人女性的面孔，并利用计算机平均了她们的所有特征，然后将这些图像展示给大学生同龄人，在32张真实的女性面孔照片中，只有3张被评为比这些融合了所有平均特征的混合照片更具吸引力，所以这真的很有趣，这种平均感和对称性的概念非常重要，他们其实并不知道为什么，嗯，显然世界并不共享来自美国某大学的白人学生的性理想。
But like I said, despite widely dissimilar standards of beauty and sex appeal, there are some of those common traits, like the symmetry of the face, the small nose, the large eyes, good complexion. People are also drawn to partners and attracted to people who they regard as clean, which makes sense because you don't want to date someone. who has poor hygiene, that is really grossed. And men in most places, they generally prefer plump, wide-hipped women to slim ones, women prefer broad-shouldered men. So it looks really count in attraction. And so does money, which makes sense.
但就像我说的，尽管对美和性吸引力的标准有很大差异，但还是有一些共同特征，比如面部对称、小鼻子、大眼睛、好肤色。人们也被伴侣吸引，并被那些被他们视为什么干净的人吸引，这很有道理，因为你不会想和一个卫生习惯不好的人约会，那真的很恶心。而且大多数地方的男性通常喜欢丰满、臀部宽阔的女性，而不是苗条的女性，女性更喜欢宽肩膀的男性。所以外表在吸引力中确实起作用。金钱也是如此，这很合理。
Obviously, the initial attraction, you might not be able to determine how much someone is worth, maybe by the value of their clothes or something like that. But if you find out that someone has a lot of money or they're pretty, well off, you could become more attracted to them. And this is seen from rural Zulus to urban Brazilians, you know, Caucasian people in Wyoming. Men are attracted to young, good-looking women, while women are drawn to men with property and money. And these like male, female appetites, they're probably innate. You know, it's in a male's genetic advantage to fall in love and be attracted to a woman who provides and who could produce viable offspring. And it's in a woman's
显然，最初的吸引力，你可能无法确定某人值多少钱，也许可以通过他们衣服的价值或其他东西来判断。但如果你发现某人有很多钱或者他们很富有，你可能会更被他们吸引。从祖鲁农村到巴西城市，你可以看到这一点（你知道，怀俄明州的白人）。男性被年轻、长相好的女性吸引，而女性则被有房产和金钱的男性吸引。这些男性和女性的欲望，可能是天生的。你知道，爱上并被一个能提供照顾且能产下健康后代的女性吸引，符合男性的基因优势。而吸引一个能够支持年轻家庭或后代的男性，这在传统上和进化角度上符合女性的
biological advantage traditionally and from an evolutionary standpoint to be attracted to a man who can help her support a young family or, you know, offspring. This can influence love at first sight because we're often immediately captivated by characteristics that fit our love map and feel an insane attraction to that person if they kind of check off things that in our brain circuitry we know would make us happy and aroused and give us that serotonin rush. And then I think the other thing is we also create expectations for this person that we have this instantaneous attraction for.
生物学优势。这会影响一见钟情，因为我们经常立即被符合我们爱图谱的特征所吸引，如果那个在我们大脑电路中我们知道会让我们快乐、兴奋并给我们带来血清素激增的东西打勾的话，我们就会对那个人产生疯狂的吸引力。然后我认为另一件事是，我们也会对这个让我们瞬间产生吸引力的人设定期望。
And when people meet those expectations, it's a self-fulfilling prophecy that makes you kind of feel like you've loved them since the beginning, since you first laid eyes on them. Another important consideration in terms of love at first sight or attraction is that it might have a critical adaptive function amongst animals, and including humans. So during the mating season, a female squirrel, for example, needs to breed.
当人们符合这些期望时，这是一个自证预言，让你感觉自己从一开始、从你第一次看到他们的时候就爱上了他们。关于一见钟情或吸引力的另一个重要考虑因素是，它可能在动物（包括人类）中具有关键的适应功能。例如，在交配季节，雌性松鼠需要繁殖。
And if she sees a healthy squirrel who probably doesn't fit her love map, but maybe the biological, physical map of what is a good partner, she really shouldn't waste any more time. She should size him up, see if he's right. And if he looks suitable, she'd probably grab the chance to copulate.
如果她看到一只健康的松鼠，这只松鼠可能不符合她的爱图谱，但可能符合好伴侣的生物学、身体地图，她真的不应该再浪费时间了。她应该打量他，看他是否合适。如果他看起来合适，她可能会抓住交配的机会。
She needs to have babies. That's what her instinct is driving her towards. So perhaps love at first sight, it's no more than an inborn tendency in many creatures that has evolved to spur the mating process. And then among our human ancestors, what has been animal attraction involved into a human sensation of infatuation at a glance and love at first sight. So we've talked about proximity, we've talked about similarity, reciprocal feelings, what else, physical attractiveness. But then there's familiarity. And this might be the most important.
她需要生孩子。这就是她的本能驱使她去做的。因此，也许一见钟情不过是许多生物生来就有的倾向，这种倾向是为了刺激交配过程而演变而来的。然后在我们的人类祖先中，动物的吸引力已经演变成人类一眼就能感受到的迷恋和一见钟情。我们讨论了邻近性、相似性、互惠感情，还有什么，外表吸引力。但接下来是熟悉度。这可能是最重要的
important factor that kind of runs through them all. When research participants rated the attractiveness of faces, they rated the faces that most matched or looked like their own as the most attractive. This is because people who are similar to us will also feel familiar to us. And it's reciprocal liking again, people who look like each other. If we see someone a lot, and we begin to understand their faces have become familiar to us. And that makes us feel comfortable and it makes us feel acknowledged in some ways and validated, which I just think is really interesting, like how that kind of comes about, how we, you know, people who are familiar are more attractive because of that proximity, but also because we become to understand their facial features
因素，它贯穿了所有这些因素。当研究参与者对面孔的吸引力进行评分时，他们给那些最匹配或最像他们自己的面孔的评分最高。这是因为与我们相似的人也会让我们感到熟悉。这又是互惠好感，长相相似的人。如果我们经常看到某人，我们开始理解他们的面孔对我们来说已经变得熟悉了。这让我们感到舒适，并在某种程度上让我们感到被认可和肯定，我只是觉得这真的很有趣，它是如何发生的，我们如何，你知道的，因为这种邻近性，熟悉的人更有吸引力，但也因为我们开始理解他们的面部特征，并在他们身边感到一种舒适感。
and feel a sense of comfort around them. So let's jump into some theories of interpersonal attraction, which has kind of been coming towards this. So there are a few. The first one, the most prominent idea in psychology is social exchange theory. This is the idea that people's feelings about attraction and a relationship depends on the perceptions of rewards and costs. The kind of relationship they deserve and their chances for having a better relationship with someone else. We really want to find the best relationship that we can get. So the rewards that we might, you know, kind of way up when we first find someone attractive, are the positive gratifying aspects of a potential relationship
因此，让我们来看看人际吸引力的几种理论，这正是我们一直要探讨的方向。有几种理论。第一种，心理学中最突出的观点是社会交换理论。这个观点认为，人们对吸引力和一段关系的感受取决于对回报和成本的看法。他们应得的关系以及他们与其他人建立更好关系的机会。我们真的很想找到我们能得到的最好的关系。因此，当我们第一次发现某人有吸引力时，我们可能会权衡的回报，是潜在关系中积极的、令人满意的方面，
that make it worthwhile. This might include things like status and physical attractiveness or money, as we were considering before. But then there's the costs, and all friendships and relationships, they have some costs. However, if rewards outweigh costs, will probably pursue that person we find attractive. And this is all dependent on comparison level
这使其值得付出。这可能包括地位、外表吸引力或金钱等方面，正如我们之前考虑的那样。但也有成本，所有的友谊和关系都有一些成本。然而，如果回报大于成本，我们可能会追求那个我们觉得有吸引力的人。这一切都取决于比较水平
relative to expectations, experience, alternatives. if a relationship doesn't match our comparison level of what we expect, we will be unhappy. And it really depends on our point of view. People with a low comparison level, they're more likely to stay in costly relationships, which is quite sad. Like if you don't believe you can do better,
相对于期望、经验、替代方案。如果一段关系不符合我们对所期望的比较水平，我们就会不快乐。这完全取决于我们的观点。比较水平低的人更有可能留在代价高昂的关系中，这很令人悲伤。就像如果你认为自己做不到更好，
that first person you find attractive might just be the one and you might just stick it out with them. There's another idea of equity theory. And this is the idea that people are happiest in relationships where they initially feel attracted to someone when the rewards and costs experienced are shared by both parties equally. So basically what that means is neither one is giving too much.
你觉得有吸引力的第一个人可能就是那个人，你可能会坚持跟他在一起。还有另一个观点是公平理论。这个观点认为，当双方经历的回报和成本均等共享时，人们在最初对某人产生吸引力的关系中会最快乐。所以基本上这意味着没有人付出太多。
You know, you're not going to be attracted to someone who never texts you back or maybe you will or who, you know, makes you feel like they don't want you there or that they don't like you. We're going to be attracted to someone who gives as much as we give into a relationship. And equitable relationships, they're the most happy. and the most stable. And it's a pretty powerful social norm equity. We want both people to benefit
你知道，你不会被一个从不回你信息的人吸引，或者也许你会，或者一个让你觉得他们不希望你在那里或他们不喜欢你的人吸引。我们会倾向于被一个在关系中付出与我们一样多的人吸引。公平的关系是最快乐的，也是最稳定的。公平是一种相当强大的社会规范。我们希望双方都受益
equally and people kind of prefer to be the one who benefits more. So it's more of a problem for those who are under-benefited. So making sure that it's an equal kind of standing is really good for those long-term relationships. Let's kind of break down that cycle of long-term loving relationships because we have that initial intense liking stage of attraction, and that's called passionate love. But that kind of moves on to companion love as we know someone more when that initial attraction, that excitement, that spark begins to fade. So starting with passionate love, it's kind of been what we've been talking about this whole time. It tends to refer to attraction and love that's characterized by high arousal, intense attraction and fear of rejection. The important aspect is
均等，人们倾向于成为受益更多的那个人。因此，这对那些受益较少的人来说是个大问题。因此，确保平等的地位对那些长期的关系非常有利。让我们剖析一下长期恋爱关系的循环，因为我们有最初强烈的吸引力好感阶段，这被称为激情之恋。但随着我们对某人的了解加深，当最初的吸引力、兴奋感和火花开始消退时，这种感情就会转化为伴侣之爱。从激情之恋开始，这基本上就是我们一直在讨论的内容。它往往指以高唤醒度、强烈的吸引力和对拒绝的恐惧为特征的吸引力和爱。重要的方面是
that the person has to attribute arousal to the right target for passionate love to emerge. So sometimes we can confuse arousal and love. And this is called excitation transfer. Excitation transfer, I don't think many people, it's not really like a big theory in psychology, which I'm kind of surprised about because it makes a lot of sense. And it comes from this study called love on the bridge. So there's two bridges. One bridge has a tendency to tilt.
为了让激情之恋涌现，这个人必须将唤醒归因于正确的对象。有时我们会混淆唤醒和爱。这被称为唤醒转移。唤醒转移，我不认为很多人知道，它在心理学中其实算不上是一个大理论，这让我有点惊讶，因为它非常合乎情理。它源于一项名为“桥上的爱”的研究。这里有两座桥。其中一座桥往往会倾斜，
and sway and feel unstable and kind of shake around. And the other bridge feels a lot safer. It does not sway. It's not that high up. It's made of concrete. It's very stable. The first bridge, obviously, is going to generate a lot more arousal. So we have these participants, male participants,
摇晃，感觉不稳定，四处晃动，而另一座桥感觉安全得多。它不会摇晃。它没有那么高。它是水泥砌的，非常稳定。第一座桥显然会产生更多的唤醒。所以我们有这些参与者，男性参与者，
and they were approached on either of the bridges by an attractive female experimenter. And that experimental, they asked the participant to tell them a story about a relationship. And in the suspension bridge condition, where there's a swaying and an instability, the men wrote more sexual stories and were more likely to call the experimenter to see if their date with this attractive female confederate went well. However, those in the controlled safe bridge condition wrote significantly less sexual stories and only 13% of them called the experimenter. So this is evidence of excitation transfer. participants on the unsafe bridge were more aroused but attributed this arousal to meeting the woman, not the bridge, whereas those on the safer bridge didn't feel that same level of physiological arousal. So kind of what this all comes down to is romantic love.
他们在其中一座桥上遇到了一个有吸引力的女性实验员。那个实验员要求参与者给他们讲一个关于恋爱关系的故事。在吊桥条件下，由于桥面晃动且不稳定，男士们写出了更多带有性色彩的故事，并且更有可能给实验员打电话，看看他们和这位有吸引力的女性同谋的约会是否顺利。然而，在对照组的安全桥条件下，他们写的带性色彩的故事明显较少，只有13%的人给实验员打了电话。所以这是激情转移的证据。不安全桥上的参与者更兴奋，但他们把这种兴奋归因于遇到了这位女性，而不是桥，而在比较安全的桥上的人并没有感受到同等程度的生理唤醒。所以这一切归根结底就是浪漫的爱情。
We have that attraction, but how does that create romantic love? Interestingly enough, a lot of research has been done into this, and romantic love seems to have a lifespan. passionate love has a lifespan more like it. That attraction is only really going to last 18 to 20 months. So, you know, if you're lucky, you've got like a year, oh, two years, sorry, like a year and a half, two years of that attraction. And after that, when relationships do last, companion love appears to be what really sustains a relationship. And this refers companion love. This refers to affection we feel for those whom our lives are deeply entwined to. It's a secure trusting partnership.
我们有那种吸引力，但那又是如何创造出浪漫爱情的呢？有趣的是，人们对此做了很多研究，浪漫爱情似乎有一个生命周期。准确地说，是热恋有生命周期。这种吸引力实际上只能持续18到20个月。所以，你知道，如果你幸运的话，你大概有一年，哦，两年，抱歉，大概一年半、两年的这种吸引力。在那之后，当关系确实持续下去时，伴侣之爱似乎才是真正维持关系的力量。这指的是伴侣之爱。这指的是我们对那些生命与我们紧密交织的人感到的情感。这是一种安全、信任的伙伴关系。
So most common responses amongst married couples have been together for more than 15 years when asked about how their married lasted is that their partner is their best friend, or they like their partner as a person. So what enables these kind of close relationships to form? That is what we are going to discuss in this next segment, I guess. Okay, so there are three important factors that enable close relationships. Number one, attachment style. Number two, equity, which we kind of already talked about. Number three is self-disclosure. Starting with attachment style. So attachment theory, it's really
因此，当被问及婚姻如何维持时，结婚超过15年的已婚夫妇最常见的回答是，他们的伴侣是他们最好的朋友，或者他们作为一个人很喜欢他们的伴侣。那么，是什么促成了这种亲密关系的形成呢？我想，这就是我们接下来要讨论的内容。好的，有三个重要因素促成了亲密关系。第一，依恋风格。第二，公平，我们之前已经讨论过了。第三是自我表露。从依恋风格开始。所以依恋理论，它现在
really popular these days in pop culture, but it suggests that a particular, we learn a particular attachment style as infants from our caregivers. And this kind of becomes our working model and what attraction and relationship should look like later in life. There's kind of a bit of debate about how many there are, but I think they're therefore. So secure, this is rooted in trust and marked by intimacy. Preoccupied, it's marked by someone's own sense of unworthiness and anxiety within a relationship. We have dismissive, this is an avoidant relationship marked by distrust for others and fearful, and it's an avoidant relationship marked by a fear of rejection. So those with secure attachment styles are most successful in romantic relationships where attraction has initially formed or
在流行文化中非常受欢迎，但它表明，我们作为婴儿从抚养者那里学到了一种特定的依恋风格。这在以后的人生中成为了我们的工作模式，也成为了吸引力和关系应该具有的样子。关于有多少种依恋风格，其实还有一些争论，但我认为它们因此分为四种。第一种是安全型，这根植于信任并以亲密为特征。第二种是痴迷型，其特征是个人在关系中感到自身不配和焦虑。我们还有疏离型，这是一种回避型的关系，其特征是对他人不信任，以及恐惧型，这是一种以害怕被拒绝为特征的回避型关系。因此，那些拥有安全型依恋风格的人在最初形成吸引力的浪漫关系中最成功，或者
passionate love has initially formed. They also appear to have more enduring relationships and they report more satisfaction. It's important though, I think we see a lot of like TikToks and Instagram reels and it's everywhere about what your attachment style is and it's not predictive. It is in part determined by the person you're with, their behavior and the state of your relationships. And human brains are also plastic so you can change what your attachment style is and unlearn schemers or things that you've learned from your parents. or other caregivers or people around you. Equity.
最初形成热恋的关系。他们似乎也拥有更持久的关系，并且报告了更高的满意度。不过，我认为这很重要，我们在抖音和Instagram Reels上经常看到关于你的依恋风格是什么的内容，而且它并不是完全可预测的。它在很大程度上取决于与你在一起的人、他们的行为以及你们关系的现状。而且人类的大脑也是具有可塑性的，所以你可以改变你的依恋风格，忘掉那些图式，或者从父母、其他照顾者或你周围的人那里学到的东西。公平。
So this is a condition under which the outcomes that people receive are proportional to what they contribute to a relationship. So people in a stable, long-term relationship, they're unconcerned with short-term equity and tend not to keep track of what they're giving and receiving. And this is a really healthy long-term equity strategy. If you're not keeping track of who's giving more, you often tend to be happier because it always comes around.
所以这是一种状况，在这种状况下，人们得到的结果与他们对关系的贡献成正比。因此，处于稳定、长期关系中的人们并不关心短期的公平，往往也不会去记录他们付出和得到了什么。这是一种非常健康的长期公平策略。如果你不记录是谁付出的更多，你往往会觉得更快乐，因为付出总会有回报的。
Finally, self-disclosure, and this is the thing I kind of find most interesting. So this kind of refers to revealing intimate aspects of one's self to others, and this really creates greater attraction and a more deep attraction and connection. So in persistent growing relationships, partners often show increasing self-disclosure, and this seems to be driven by principles of disclosure reciprocity and the tendency to match each other's level of self-disclosure. Attraction, like we've discussed, it builds from biology, but it is moulded by our environment,
最后是自我表露，这是我觉得最有趣的事情。这有点类似于向他人展现自己私密的一面，这确实会产生更大的吸引力以及更深层次的吸引力和连接。因此，在不断发展的关系中，伴侣们通常会表现出越来越多的自我表露，这似乎是由表露互惠的原则以及彼此迎合自我表露水平的倾向所驱动的。正如我们所讨论的，吸引力建立在生物学的基础之上，但它是由我们的环境塑造的，
and we can eventually create long-lasting, stable love from that initial spark if we follow kind of some of those almost rules of equity and self-disclosure and trust. But I just think it's really interesting. You know, we've kind of investigated and talked about that initial feeling and that hormonal rush, you know, due to voice. due to smell and due to attractiveness. But then when we add in factors like proximity and familiarity, reciprocity and similarity, it shows that, you know, it's kind of almost deterministic who we fall for, who we find
如果我们遵循几乎类似于公平、自我表露和信任的某些规则，我们最终可以从最初的火花中创造出长久、稳定的爱。但我只是觉得这真的很有趣。你知道，我们已经调查并讨论了那种最初的感觉和荷尔蒙的冲动，你知道的，因为声音、因为气味以及因为吸引力。但随后，当我们加入邻近度、熟悉度、互惠性和相似性等因素时，它表明，你知道，我们会被谁吸引，我们觉得谁有吸引力，几乎是命中注定的。
attractive. It's probably, you know, someone you live close to, someone you see a lot, someone who you have things in common with, someone from your neighborhood. So we may not have as much choice as we think. Anyhow, I hope that episode was informative. I hope that you've learned something about maybe your. type, your love map, what makes you attracted to certain people and not to others. And I think that's super important in our 20s. We're attracted to a lot of people. People are really attractive. We're all
这可能，你知道的，是你住在附近的人，你经常看到的人，和你有很多共同点的人，你邻居里的人。所以我们的选择可能没有我们想象的那么多。无论如何，希望这一集能给你带来启发。我希望你已经了解了关于你的类型、你的爱图（love map）、是什么让你被某些人吸引而不是其他人的一些知识。我认为这在我们20岁时超级重要。我们会对很多人产生吸引力。人们真的很有吸引力。我们都在
wanting to bang because, I don't know, it's that time. So knowing like why you fall for those certain people is really important, I think, or just interesting to know, like next time you find yourself having a crush. Think about some of those factors that we've talked about. You know, is it just because they're like your next door neighbor or just because you both like Star Wars or something like that. Obviously not to be taken too seriously. I'm not a professional. But I hope that you enjoyed this episode and I'm yeah, I'm back on the podcast grind. So more episodes are coming in the future. I think next week we're definitely going to talk about the psychology of life transitions, which is a huge thing for your 20s and yeah, that anxiety around it as well. And if you like this
想要上床，因为，我不知道，那是个荷尔蒙蓬勃的时期。所以了解你为什么会被特定的人吸引真的很重要，我认为，或者说，下次当你发现自己对某人动心时，了解这一点会很有趣。想想我们讨论过的一些因素。你知道，这只是因为他们就像你隔壁的邻居，还是因为你们都喜欢《星球大战》之类的东西？当然，这不用太认真对待。我不是专业人士。但我希望你喜欢这一集，是的，我又回到了播客的日常创作中。所以未来会有更多集。我想下周我们肯定会讨论生活过渡期的心理学，这对20多岁的人来说是一件大事，是的，还有与之相关的焦虑。如果你喜欢这一
episode, remember to subscribe the podcast. It's on Apple, Spotify. Google, so many other places. And thanks to all the support and thanks for bearing with me while I had a little break. Can't wait to record a few more things soon. And thank you for listening. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs
集，记得订阅这个播客。它在苹果、Spotify、谷歌以及许多其他平台上。感谢所有的支持，也感谢大家在我短暂休息时的包容。等不及很快再录制一些新内容了。谢谢收听。2%。这就是走楼梯的人所占的比例
when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side.
当旁边也有自动扶梯可用的时候。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理坚韧、健身和抗压能力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端脱胎换骨。
a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. In 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam J.
成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是IHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方的TWA%。在《Look Back At It》播客中。1979年，对那对我来说是个重要时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J。
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games.
我是亚历克斯·英格利希。每一集，我们都会选择一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、喜剧同仁以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back At It》。嘿，大家好，你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。
This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen and learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. This is an IHart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，这些对话在任何地方都不安全，但你正在与一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行这些对话。有多少男人穿着一套铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这么做，在IHard电台应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听并学习艰难的方式。这是一个IHeart播客。保证是真人。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。